hey guys well you know how often our  predictions are wrong on who's gonna win  a tournament and who's gonna come on top  so I asked the guys who will really know  the kids here at the London chess  classic let's see what they think is  gonna happen in the grand gesture  I think it's fishy Anand why because  when I saw him he was playing really  well Magnus Carlsen he's the best player  Carlsen I've know I'd say um Magnus  Carlsen why do you think that cuz he's  like the defending World Campus racer  you know my money's on him Magnus  Carlsen Vishy Anand and vichy Carlsen  Vishy Anand  because I've seen him and those of  newspapers and says that he's really  good Clarkson is going to win baby  Magnus Carlsen  I think Carlson is because I mean he  just wins everything  never Lauren young never millenium why  because it's best chess player ever  simply well there you go guys much love  for Magnus and vichy here in London but  we got to love all the players or Hey